All right. Now that we've learned the basics of visual
cues, different data types, and different skills that we might
use to plot those data types. Why don't we focus
in more on time series data? Since that's the format
that our New York City subway data and weather data
will come in. We'll discuss different things we can include
in the plot for time series data Starting with something
simple like a scatterplot, and adding more complex features like
maybe a Louis curve. With each iteration, we'll
show how we can combine visual cues, data
types, and appropriate scales in our charts to
achieve visual excellence. Again, why don't we use baseball
data as an example. Let's plot the winning
percentage of my least favorite team as a
Yankees fan, the Boston Red Sox, from 1960
until 2010. Let's start with a simple scatter plot.